the goal of this video is to feel good
about the connection that we've talked
about between the absolute value of the
determinant of a two by two matrix and
the area of the parallelogram that's
defined by the two column vectors of
that matrix so for example i have this
column vector right over here ac
so that's this blue vector so this
distance right over here it goes a in
the x direction so this distance right
over here is a
and then it goes c in the y direction so
this distance right over here is equal
to c and so this distance up here is
also
equal to a and this is also equal to c
so we have this vector and then we have
the bd vector
and bd vector so in the x direction it
goes a distance of b
right over there or if we draw it over
here goes a distance of b and in the
vertical direction it goes a distance of
d
so this right over here is d
and this distance right over here is d
and we can see that the parallelogram
created or defined by those two vectors
its area is right over there
now let's see if we can connect that to
the determinant or the absolute value of
the determinant of this matrix and we're
just going to assume for the sake of
simplicity that a b c and d are positive
values although we can in the future do
this same thing where we had some other
combination where some of them are not
positive but this will hopefully give
you a clue of how we can prove it
now how can we figure out the area of
this parallelogram
well one technique would be find the
area of this larger rectangle
right over here
and then from that subtract out the
parts that are not in the parallelogram
and so let's do that so what's the area
of this larger rectangle
let's see the dimensions here are this
length from here to here is a
and then from here to here is b
so this is a plus b on this side and on
this side up here
this part is d and then this part is c
right over here so it's d plus c so the
area of the whole thing
is going to be
a plus b
times d plus c which is equal to we just
do the distributive property a few times
it's going to be a
d plus
a c
plus b d
plus b c
now from that we're going to want to
subtract out all of these other parts
that are not in the parallelogram so
let's do that so you have this triangle
right over here whose area would be ac
over 2 a times c over 2 but you also
have this one which has the same area so
if we subtract both of them out we'd
want to subtract out a total of ac each
of those are ac over 2. so to count both
of them let's subtract out an ac
and then of course we could do these two
triangles
and the area of each of these triangles
is b d over two b times d over two but
add them together their combined area is
b d so let's subtract that out minus b d
and now what is the area of this right
over here well that is b
times c
so minus b times c actually and that's
also the area of this right over here so
we have another b times c so minus 2
bc so let's see what's going on
so if we subtract these out that takes
out that
that takes out that and if you take bc
minus 2 bc we're going to be left with
just a negative bc
so all of this is going to be equal to a
d what we have there bc minus 2 bc is
just going to be a negative bc
well this is going to be the determinant
of our matrix a times d minus b times c
so this isn't a proof that for any a b c
or d the absolute value of the
determinant is equal to this area but it
shows you the case where you have a
positive determinant and all of these
values are positive so hopefully that
feels somewhat satisfying and you could
try if you like to prove the cases if
you don't have a positive determinant or
if some combination of these are
negative